so now we've had a chance to explore
market segmentation we're going to dive
into some exercises and we want you to
be able to be involved even if you don't
have an idea of your own yet so ronnie
and i have some exciting news we want to
share with you
we decided to create embarkment
many entrepreneurs our idea came from
passion and need lauren is obsessed with
dogs that's that's very true and i'm
passionate about finding good safe and
fun place for my dog to stay while i
travel for work
so ronnie needs reliable and affordable
place for a dog and i need to spend more
time with dogs because i can't have my
own right now plus i could use the extra
cash we figured we were not alone in how
we felt and what we needed so we decided
to create a bargain a safe home for your
dog to stay in with people who are
excited to spend time with your dog
while you're away so the idea is simple
you sign up for our app as either a
sitter and tell us your availability and
about the environment you'll be keeping
the visiting dog in
or sign up as an owner and tell us what
you're looking for in a theater and when
you'll be away we will match you with
the best sitter for your dog at a
reasonable price so we need to use
market segmentation to come up with a
marketing plan obviously the first cash
should be sitters versus owners but even
within each of these we have to
understand who are the different users
and who to focus on
why don't you join our team and help us
conduct a market segmentation for
embarkment you can start with one
practice of market segmentation and then
try another until you have a solid
segmentation of the market